Oh what are you gonna call this I don't
know any ideas if something American
girl you gotta do something with
American the actual the American greed
episode yeah
something narrated by Secret Service
Special Agent Andrea peacock is on the
tail of Matt Cox and Rebecca Hawk two of
the most wanted financial fugitives but
the Secret Service is never sure where
they are of what names they're using it
was impossible to predict what identity
he would use next Cox has as many 50
aliases
they have Oliver jr. Phillip Daniel
Morgan Corbin Blair Thomas Matthew Bevan
Cox Sunday Herald scott keebler
Walter Andrew Holcomb Richard Paul
groggy jr. James Franklin paid do they
do just the part a thousand such as the
cried a box and Hawk pull into Columbia
South Carolina where Bridget Brown and
her husband are trying to sell their
home this is a flyer that their realtor
produced to show our home when we were
trying to sell it shows a quintessential
suburban neighborhood and little house
on a pond try as they may the home won't
sell it was a stressful time as I was
traveling weekly two of us already with
my son for his surgical treatments their
son Colby is sick and they need to move
closer to care in Augusta Georgia
of no idea the old house continues I
just say they have a sick son until the
Brussels decide to try this year later
you a friend of ours recommended that we
offer owner financing so that that would
make the home competitive and also open
it up to people that previously could
not have afforded a conventional loan
just one week after the Browns offer
owner financing the phone rings that
night it was Gary Sullivan or the man we
thought was very soft no one that Cox as
a new alien was it was there I never
talked to her or the husband until the
day of we went to closing what happened
was I had hired an attorney I had hired
a real not hired I got a realtor yeah we
went to a bunch of different properties
and I put and properties that people
were willing to own or finance so I
would walk in the property I look around
I say okay great what do they want for
it 110 thousand put $110,000 contract on
it and they go okay and I wanted to own
a finance that 10% down no problem I
leave I put half a dozen contracts out
okay one of the I got two houses got a
house for 110,000 which I bars like
ninety several about four or five loans
for around ninety to ninety five
thousand dollars on like half a million
like three four hundred thousand dollars
on on one house their house was going
for 224 225 so I go in I walk in I look
at the house I go great how much they
want to twenty four let's say tuna 225
225 thousand I say okay great put a
contract in I'll put 10% down like okay
no problem but they got owner financing
no problem so they call me back
realtor calls back hey well how's this
gonna work I talked to the realtor for a
little bit here I'll do this I'll do
this I'll do this put 10% down he goes
okay no problem
he calls back and said they'll do it
it's a little bit longer dragged out the
phone calls a little bit longer but
whatever within a few hours like that
night like after I see the house like
that that night or the next night I got
a they're ready to sign a contract I've
never talked to him okay I don't know
anything about any sick child nobody was
there she says at one point she says
that like
he was there when I walked in and
Rebecca Hulk walked in but I had a male
realtor that walked in with me and no
one was in the home nobody was there so
maybe she's miss remembering it I don't
know just like she said I called her I
didn't call it you had a realtor you
call her a liar I'm saying that's not
what happened what's he saying I'm
saying I talked to my realtor my realtor
talk to their realtor their realtor at
some point contacted me I never talked
first of all if you have a realtor you
don't talk to the buyer you talked the
Realtors are talking that's what you're
paying them for you're not talking to
him I never talk to her till the day of
the closing hmm so then we have the day
of the closing and I walk in this part I
do remember because she said this a few
times I walk in we all meet hi how are
you one of the things they wanted me to
do was to write out all the cults like
18 months with the checks there's not
like a year's worth of checks so they
just deposit him and I had suggested
that so I ride all the checks out
January forevermore whatever here and
she says and as we're talking I remember
her saying she was joking around above
we said something and when I was talking
to her I had Invisalign in the braces I
said I'm sorry I have these braces in
and I like to pop them out and she goes
oh you got worried your teeth when I go
out there a little bit tweak that it's
trying to fix him up I said you know I
made a crack I said listen when you're
five foot six I said everything's got to
be perfect
said the hair the face the teeth the
wardrobe the bank account everything she
starts laughing um and I remember her
husband was like he's like six foot tall
I go I go mr. dot who was a doctor dr.
Brown I go dr. Brown wouldn't know
anything about that and she starts she
looked at him and laughs and uh so I
write the checks and she says something
about well when I we give out the
document like we give out our driver's
license she says something about oh yeah
something something yeah I had my
identity stolen one time and I like
looked at her like like was it like [ __ ]
and I was like oh okay really and she's
like yeah and I'm sitting there bribing
remember thinking just that the idea
that she had said it
and she says at one in one of these
interviews someone maybe not this one
was one of them she says he looked at me
with this shocked look on his face like
when I endure my identity even stole
something like that anyway so we had we
all signed the documents I give him the
twenty five my ten percent down which
was like 25 grand and and I leave I make
a few payments I satisfied a loan I
borrow like a million dollars or so on
their house I pull out the money you
know I get caught in the bank the whole
you know the whole thing a year and a
half a year about a year later fortune
magazine comes out and it says that I
stalked them because I knew that they
had a sick child and they were desperate
to sell the house I didn't know you were
desperate I didn't know you had a sick
child I didn't know you I was driven
around by a realtor I put a contract out
on a contract on the house I borrowed
the money what I did was wrong I
absolutely went to prison for that I am
sorry for that I I owe them she's gonna
say that I I like stole $200,000 from
them or something no I didn't you had a
mortgage on the house for two hundred
and one thousand dollars of what you
owed sold the house for 225 I put down
twenty five thousand you own a finance
two hundred thousand you had what's
called a wraparound mortgage you I make
payments to them they make payments to
their lender you didn't have any equity
you were getting money to pay your - I
owe you two hundred thousand in equity
that you don't possess because the
equity is actually held by the by the
lender right so I'm paying you you're
paying the lender you don't have any
equity you already owe yo two hundred
thousand now I want you balance like you
just go back to paying their own
mortgage right so well they can
foreclose I think oh you still foreclose
on they can foreclose on me take that
they did for they foreclose took the
house back and resold the house oh [ __ ]
okay but I do owe them about ten grand
because they thought they hired an
attorney hmm - because I I in come burn
stare their title so I absolutely owe
them oh then the 10th out and they're
they're all my on my restitution payment
for ten grand that's what I owe him okay
but he or she says oh he took I think
she says I stole two hundred thousand
from her something but you didn't have
two thousand two hundred thousand in
equity that's it's just one of those
things is tweaked not that what I did
wasn't wrong it's just one of those
things that they they just a little bit
here just enough to make you a you know
like I've said before it's like me
arguing the point is like saying I
didn't murder ten people I only murdered
seven yeah it's okay well I'm still
scumbag I'm not saying nobody's saying
I'm not a scumbag I'm just saying I
didn't murder ten people I have murdered
seven which is why we're doing this my
bad
[Music]
[Laughter]